[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici les titres de ce vendredi 27
octobre faciliter les rencontres avec
les citoyens restent en contact avec le
terrain ce sont les principaux objectifs
des permanences itinérantes mises en
place par de nombreux élus locaux dans
la troisième circonscription des
yvelines
la députée de la république en marche
béatrice pire on était présente ce
vendredi à villepreux françois bélanger
notre invité fil rouge pour cette
émission président d'honneur de la
confédération française des retraités
nous évoquerons notamment avec lui la
hausse de la csg qui concernera deux
millions et demi de retraités sans
compensation l'an prochain enfin dans le
reste de l'actualité locale retour sur
la recherche de mécènes pour le potager
du roi à versailles ou encore la mise en
place du périmètre urbain à guyancourt
c'était donc une promesse de la campagne
des élections législatives en plus de sa
permanence fixé à bailly la députée de
la république en marge de la 3ème
circonscription des yvelines
béatrice piron a lancé au mois de
septembre un cycle de permanences
itinérantes le principe est simple
l'élu va directement à la rencontre des
habitants de la circonscription qui
comprend 13 communes
ce matin le rendez vous était fixé à
villepreux patrick jacques de dixmude et
grégory canal et elle essaye de tenir un
rythme d'environ 9 permanences
itinérantes par mois mais une fois n'est
pas coutume ce matin il n'y avait
personne pour rencontrer et béatrice
piron à l'hôtel de ville de villepreux
lé rendez vous programmé ces temps
annulé en dernière minute
en général j'ai deux ou trois rendez
vous parlera par séance alors ça semble
s'estomper un petit peu parce qu'il y
avait au départ beaucoup d'attentes donc
j'avais eu jusqu'à quatre rendez vous
plus quand on demande au mois de
septembre
et là lorsque ce sont les vacances ou
pas ça commence à se calmer un petit peu
présentes à l'assemblée nationale du
mardi au jeudi la députée a bloqué sur
son agenda les lundi et vendredi pour
rencontrer la population
elle va se rendre ainsi régulièrement
dans douze des treize communes de la
circonscription
la ville du chesnay a refusé
d'accueillir la parlementaire faute de
salle disponible
ces moments de discussions permettent à
l'élu de rester connectés avec son
territoire ça me permet de découvrir et
de mieux appréhender du mes dossiers au
lieu d'être purement législatif
je prends connaissance de faits
particuliers de dossiers particuliers
sein permet aussi de rentrer en contact
avec des élus ou des administrations du
département les sujets abordés lors des
permanences itinérantes sont variés des
difficultés avec l'administration aux
problèmes routiers
une démarche de rencontre qui plaît aux
villes prévient même s'il regrette de ne
pas avoir été mise au courant de la
venue de leur député
non je pense à très bien qu'elle aille
au contact des gens tu très importante
parce que franchement on peut on peut
les rencontrer on peut leur parler
ah je trouve excellente à partir du
moment où on nous prévient mais là on
n'a pas été prévenu non ne savait pas il
n'ya pas d'affichés rien
prochaines permanences itinérantes le 3
novembre à la mairie des
clayes-sous-bois lé rencontre avec l'élu
se font uniquement sur rendez vous les
opposants d'emmanuel macro évoque une
mesure profondément injuste le
gouvernement et les parlementaires de la
république en marche eux évoquent une
mesure qui va revaloriser le travail
j'évoque évidemment la hausse de la csg
qui a été votée dans la nuit de mercredi
à jeudi à l'assemblée nationale elle
concernera notamment tous les retraités
qui gagnent plus de 1400 euros par mois
alors est ce une mesure réellement
injuste nous allons poser la question à
notre invité fil rouge de ce vendredi
françois bélanger bonsoir bons soins
françois bélanger vous êtes le président
d'honneur de la confédération française
des retraités une association une
association excusez moi qui vise à faire
entendre comme son nom l'indiqué le
droit des retraités est donc en toute
logique on comprend que vous êtes
opposés à cette hausse de la csg qui va
impacter les retraités dans un
communiqué votre confédération indique
notamment quelques il s'agit
d'ostracisme
le mot est assez assez assez fort est-ce
que selon vous aujourd'hui on cherche à
marche
alizée clairement les retraités de la
société non je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
fois que la confédération s'est
réellement exprimés comme ça par contre
la grogne monte de plus en plus pourquoi
parce qu' effectivement autant si vous
voulez la hausse de la csg n'était pas
en soi quelque chose contre laquelle la
confédération
ce fut ce qu'est la confédération des
adhérentes qui sont des citoyens à part
entière ils le comprennent très bien
qu'on puisse lever un impôt
supplémentaire la csg et qui t'a donné
effectivement du pouvoir d'achat
supplémentaire aux actifs jusque là
c'est quelque chose que l'on peut
compenser bien que l'on peut comprendre
et que l'on peut admettre par contre il
ya des choses que l'on ne peut pas
admettre et c'est qu'effectivement
toutes les catégories sociales ont des
contreparties alors les actifs cédés
compact contrepartie carrément positive
mais les autres leur pouvoir financer
des infections par le cg mais les autres
catégories sociales ont aussi des
contreparties je cite par exemple la
fonction publique
la fonction publique bien sûr n'a pas de
fin
je veux dire les actifs payent la série
j'ai comme tout le monde mais la
fonction publique a aujourd'hui paient
une cotisation de 1 pour cent de
solidarité pour le chômage risque pas
d'être chômeur et dont il ya quelques
années une cotisation de 20 pourcent de
solidarité a été instituée à la charge
des fonctionnaires
cette cotisation va être supprimé ils
ont donc une contrepartie positive à la
suppression de la chaîne
ce qui n'est pas le cas du coup pour
pour les retraités le gouvernement
indique le gouvernement dit quand même
que pour notamment les retraités qui
vont payer la la hausse de la csg ce qui
se situe au dessus de 1400 euros
ils vont aussi bénéficier
progressivement de la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation qui va neutraliser
selon le gouvernement une nouvelle fois
qui va neutraliser l'effet et ça jusqu'à
2500 euros par mois en gros les seuls
pénalisés concrètement comme vous le
dites
ce sera ceux qui gagnent plus de 2500
euros par mois je conteste formellement
cette façon de raisonner l'exonération
de taxe d'habitation concerne tout le
monde et donc les actifs en dehors du
supplément de pouvoir d'achat dont on
vient de parler des défis seront aussi
de l'exonération de taxe d'habitation et
vous les choses en plus c'est quelque
chose en plus
alors que une idée précise par exemple
ce qu'on pourrait faire pour les pour
les retraités aujourd'hui effectivement
écrit au président le 15 juillet en lui
disant qu'effectivement il y avait un
problème du côté des retraités qui avait
deux mesures a examiné pour que les
retraités puissent se sentir traités
équitablement
première mesure les retraités du secteur
privé sont les seuls je dis bien les
seuls aujourd'hui à payer une taxe
d'assurance maladie de 1% sur les
retraites complémentaires arrco réagir
il ya une taxe l'assurance maladie
devrait vous laisse à sa suppression
je romps demandent sa suppression vous
aviez écrit au premier ministre est ce
qui vous a répondu depuis on a écrit au
président de la république dans l'artère
directement s qui est-ce qui vous a
répondu alors il nous a répondu à des
gens qu'ils transféraient le dossier
monsieur darmanin donc
le ministre en charge des comptes
publics qui assume d'ailleurs
complètement on va dire de faire payer
entre guillemets et si on peut utiliser
cette expression qui assume clairement
le gouvernement assume la politique de
faire payer clairement les plus aisés
des des retraités puisque leurs
arguments une nouvelle fois c'est de
dire que ceux qui gagnent plus de 2500
euros seront lésés dans cette de hausse
de la csg je conteste formellement c'est
pas plus de 2500 euros encore une fois
l'exonération de la taxe d'habitation
concerne tout le monde donc elle
bénéficie à tout le monde y compris les
actifs pour les retraités si vous voulez
d'abord c'est pour 1400 ses 1200 à
partir de 1200 euros
1200 euros entre 60 et 65 ans et
au-dessus de 65 ans ça sera à 1380 je
crois bon mais 1200 donc un 1200 dire
qu'on était un retraité et déjà je
trouve que c'est un abus de langage
bon mais ceci étant si vous voulez
encore une fois les tout le monde à une
compensation je parle pas encore une
fois de l'exonération de la taxe
d'habitation qui concerne tout le monde
ça tout le monde l'a à condition de
remplir les chiffres qui ont été données
pour en bénéficier
par contre en dehors de ça en plus de ça
les actifs ont des compensations les
fonctionnaires ont des compensations
mais marie travailleurs indépendants ont
des compensations et les retraités
rires est-ce que vous vous comprenez
aussi peut-être la philosophie du
gouvernement une nouvelle fois qu'ils
assument et qui dit en gros que
j'utilise les mots uns de la majorité
que c'est que qu'ils assument que ce
soient les plus aisés les retraités les
plus aisés qui qui paie pour les actifs
pour pour les plus pour les plus pauvres
d'actifs est ce que vous comprenez cette
philosophie de faire payer les anciens
je comprends la philosophie mais ce que
je ne comprends pas d'ailleurs de
solidarité intergénérationnelle
justement donc d'accord pour ses moules
à mais à condition que ça corresponde à
une réalité
d'abord parlé de retraités aisés quand
on dépasse 1200 euros alors encore une
fois légèrement lui par surtout des
retraités au dessus de 2500 non mais ça
c'est un abus de langage
parce que encore une fois l'exonération
des taxes d'habitation c'est pour tout
le monde c'est pas pour les retraités
c'est pour tout le monde mais qui en
profitent aussi les retraités la
neutralise l'effet ou non les retraités
profitent mais les actifs alors qu'ils
en profitent pas peut-être donc les
actifs non ont non seulement de l'effet
de la solidarité intergénérationnelle
dont vous parlez mais en plus ils ont
l'exonération des taxes d'habitation
voilà et senna que s'ils voulaient les
retraités ne comprennent pas il ya
aucune raison qu'ils soient les seuls à
payer une cotisation de sciences m'a dit
que personne n'en payent puis personnes
physiques
je parle des personnes physiques
certains disent aussi que finalement ce
sont les retraités qui profite le plus
des soins de l'assurance maladie et ce
qui est ce qui paraît logique puisque
quand on vieillit on a peut-être plus
besoin de soins du coup est ce que lui
aussi a pas une forme de logique est ce
que ce soit les retraités qui paie un
peu plus que les autres puisque aussi on
connaît la problématique le nombre de
retraités augmente le nombre d'actifs ne
suit pas la même courbe
du coup on risque d'avoir un
déséquilibre un moment si je pense pas
que vous puissiez résoudre comme ça le
problème de la consommation médicale
plus importante des personnes âgées
c'est pas en imposant les seuls
retraités du secteur privé déjà quand
même complètement anormal et sur les
retraites complémentaires encore anormal
donc si vous voulez c'est certainement
pas une solution qui puisse s'expliquer
par la consommation supérieure de soins
de santé et des personnes âgées
plus généralement je voulais avoir une
notre réflexion avec vous sur ce fameux
ratio actifs retraités qui permet de
financer les retraites aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on est dans un système de
répartition c'est-à-dire que les actifs
paient pour les retraités d'aujourd'hui
ils cotisent aussi pour les leurs demain
on sait qu'il va y avoir un problème
avec ce ratio il ya de plus en plus de
retraités c'est une bonne nouvelle à
queue avec l'allongement de la durée de
vie la cour d'actifs ne suis pas comment
on pourrait résoudre ce problème qui
arrive qui pointe son nez tout le monde
sait que c'est une échéance importante
qui arrive quelles solutions selon vous
pourrez mettre en place revoir ce
système de répartition n'ont
certainement pas je pense que le système
de répartition est le plus sûr moyen de
gérer les retraites qui sera suffisant
de quoi long terme c'est suffisant à
condition de que les actifs partage
suffisamment avancée pour permettre un
rapport à jouer démographie pour pousser
encore l'âge de la retraite c'est ce que
soit le pousser comme le comme vous
voulez le faire françois fillon c'était
dans sa campagne il voulait vraiment et
là je retraite soit institué un système
de retraite qui incite les salariés à
travailler plus longtemps et c'est à
dire alors du en deux mots si vous
voulez la confédération française de
retraités
beaucoup travaillé sur le régime de
retraite dit suédois c'est à dire le
régime universel de retraite à points
capitale-nationale peu importe on a même
préparé un projet de loi on a passé ce
projet de loi aux équipes dans marche et
on a eu l'excellente surprise de voir
que emmanuel macron effectivement
accepté enfin le médecin dit programme
c'est plus qu'ils acceptaient mettez
dans son programme effectivement
l'institution un système de peu a
expliqué à ceux qui nous regardent mais
un régime universel des retraites ça
veut dire mêmes droits mêmes obligations
pour tous souhaité un traitement
exactement concrètement ça veut dire ça
c'est à dire une équité complète il ya
plus personne ne peut dire le voisin est
mieux traité que tout le monde est
traité de la même manière on sait croyez
ça en france vous pensez que c'est
possible de le mettre en place
beaucoup de riches il ya beaucoup de
systèmes de retraite à l'image de
beaucoup de comme si c'est à peu près
c'est l'heure le demandeur donc c'est ça
compliquera un petit peu les choses
on a dans le projet de loi on a estimé
qu'il faudrait environ cinq ans pour
mettre en place le mécanisme et je
déclenche et parce qu'il n'est pas
question d'attendre que le nouveau
quinquennat c'est pour le faire
d'ailleurs emmanuel macron c'est ce qui
la rend dans la région verra si ça se
fait ce sera peut-être dès 2018 l'inde
est l'un des chantiers dernière qui sont
très très rapidement on sait qu'en ce
moment il ya plein de mouvements sociaux
il y avait une manifestation des
retraités fin septembre votre
confédération n'a pas été on va dire
invité par les par les syndicats est ce
que vous appelez vous les retraités par
exemple à ceux à se mobiliser à
manifester leur mécontentement dans la
rue ce que des actions vont être mises
en place
ce que c'est un moyen d'action ne nous
paraît pas être un très bon moyen
d'action alors en dehors du fait qu
effectivement la même pas été invité
donc savez presse mais même si on avait
été invitée geiler que si vous faites
une manifestation qui est un échec et en
gros la dernière manifestation est un
échec
d'accord car peu de mobilisation au
moins 8 h les médias qui ne suivent pas
forcément pipi toute façon le le nombre
de jours mobilisé et est faible quand
j'avais un échec de ce type pour les
politiques c'est un aveu de faiblesse
les politiques gèrent des pouvoirs de
force des fonctions dans de la face
avant se voit donc quand vous manifestez
faiblesse et une manifestation était 7e
faiblesse est bien c'est qu'on est pas
bon adjectif
merci françois bélanger d'être venu en
plateau je rappelle que vous êtes le
président d'honneur de la confédération
française des retraités et j'ajoute
d'ailleurs que vous
vivez dans les yvelines merci encore à
vous et puis bon week-end merci
attention si vous empruntez ce week-end
les transports en commun la ligne l du
transilien sera interrompue entre paris
montparnasse et versailles chantiers
dans les deux sens de circulation trafic
stoppé deux samedi à partir de 13 heures
pour 24 heures la raison des travaux de
modernisation et extension du réseau les
lignes de bus régulières sont elles
rouvrent renforcée pour pallier le
manque de trains plus d'informations sur
transilien à point comme on passe
maintenant à l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
l'actualité marquée cette semaine par la
venue d' emmanuel macron sur le plateau
de saclay c'était mercredi un
déplacement du président de la
république sur le thème évidemment
évidemment de l'enseignement supérieur
il a réaffirmé sa volonté de créer un
territoire sur ce territoire un
véritable silicon valley à la française
plus question en revanche de regrouper
l'ensemble des établissements dans la
même structure
le pôle d'excellence du plateau sera
scindé en deux branches d'un côté
polytechnique et quatre grandes écoles
comme télécom paris sud de l'autre les
université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines paris sud et centrale
supélec notamment autre sujet abordé
mercredi celui de la métropole du grand
paris emmanuel macron a promis d'être
raisonnable sur la question sans rien
préciser de plus des annonces doivent
être faites en la matière en décembre en
politique également cette semaine
christine boutin conseillère
départementale et président d'honneur du
parti chrétien démocrate a annoncé
qu'elle mettait fin à sa carrière
politique
après quarante ans de combats qu'ils
auront vu notamment s'opposer au mariage
pour tous et au pacs la rédaction de tv
78 a rencontré l'ancienne candidate à la
présidentielle pour revenir en partie
sur son parcours extrait le fondement
idéologique
mon engagement politique et le respect
de la personne humaine de la conception
à la mort naturelle
voilà je pourrais rajouter comme une
cerise sur le gâteau et pardon pour le
fond ce qui est fait c'est que pour moi
tout homme même le pire des hommes même
le pire de mes adversaires et aimé de
dieu autant que je le suis je dois dire
que avec expérience
autant j'avais l'intuition dans le coeur
qui avait été blessé par cette loi sur
l'avortement alors que je mettais mes
enfants au monde
l'expérience de ses 40 ans m'ont montré
que si l'on touche aux plus petits
d'entre nous que nous avons tous été
c'est à dire l'embryon c'est l'humanité
tout entière qui est touchée elle n'a
pas été démissionné de son n'a pas
démissionné de son mandat excusez moi
mais a été remercié par le bureau
national du prg
et sandrine grand gangs n'est plus
secrétaire départemental du parti
cette décision est la conséquence du
choix fait par l'élu de rejoindre le
groupe europe ecologie les verts au
conseil régional d'île de france avec
son mentor politique benoît hamon c'est
le numéro 2 des socialistes dans les
yvelines désormais à lire ab qui a pris
la tête par intérim de la fédération
mieux aussi est un proche de benoît
hamon
son objectif préparer le congrès
national du ps qui se déroulera en
février 2018
à lire ab souhaite que l'union des siens
soient maintenus à tout prix on l'écouté
l'enjeu qui va se poser pour moi mais
pour tous les militants du parti
socialiste c'est est ce que le prochain
congrès sera un moment de débat et de
rassemblement du parti socialiste qui
nous permettra d'échanger réellement sur
le fond et de contribuer au relèvement
de la gauche qui ne passera pas que par
le parti socialiste
si la réponse est oui et j'espère que
c'est oui en tout cas je contribue tous
les jours et j'ai contribuerait pour ça
le soit évidemment je resterai au parti
socialiste si je constate que l'objectif
de ceux qui préparent le prochain
congrès ce sera uniquement d'éliminer
tel ou tel socialiste alors non je ne me
trouvais pas ma place à titre personnel
à versailles le saviez vous plus de 400
variétés de fruits et 3 sont de légumes
sont produites au coeur de la cité
royale au sein du potager du roi créé au
xviie siècle le lieu doit faire l'objet
d'un plan de conservation le potager
cherche donc actuellement des mécènes
pour mener à bien ce projet reportage de
camille lambert et marie pas neutre à
ses sous l'oeil bienveillant de la
quintinie que poussent ici plus de neuf
cents variétés de fruits et légumes
différents
il a créé ce jardin d'éden en 1678 pour
alimenter la cour du roi soleil en
produits frais un lieu unique en son
genre qui a traversé les siècles mais
ces fondations commence à vieillir
nous avons un système hydraulique qui
date du xviie siècle qui sait colmatée
nous avons des murs qui avec le temps
perdre leur ennui et sur laquelle est
très difficile aujourd'hui de faire
courir nos espaliers faire pousser nos
espagne et on n'est pas non plus dans
dans une situation catastrophique mais
si on n'y pense pas aujourd'hui si on
fait pas le travail aujourd'hui on
pourrait le devenir
pour mener à bien ses travaux le potager
recherchent des mécènes
classé monument historique et au
patrimoine de l'unesco c'est aussi un
campus pour l'école nationale supérieure
du paysage terrain d'expérimentation
pour les étudiants il est ouvert à tous
c'est déjà un lieu de création
culturelle avec des manifestations avec
c'était un lieu d'accueil des publics à
40000 personnes qui visitent
annuellement ce site
et c'est pour amplifier en quelque sorte
et pour donner encore plus de
rayonnement national et international
que nous avons besoin d'être accompagné
depuis plusieurs années le potager s'est
aussi lancé dans l'agro écologie la
permaculture les traitements chimiques
sont maintenant bannis comme dans cette
allée utilisés autrefois pour répandre
des pesticides la matière organique est
récupéré sur les arbres et mise en en
dha et on cultive des légumes à la place
ici sur bâche de façon à faciliter la
croissance de ces courges et de lutter
contre les adventices naturellement n'a
pas besoin de mettre d'herbicides seuls
les courges réussissent à prospérer
autant de qualités que le potager
souhaite encore développer qui ont
séduit le world monuments fund
cette année le site a été classé comme
menacés par cette organisation
américaine
un coup de projecteur pour attirer de
potentiels mécènes à guyancourt le
conseil municipal a voté récemment la
mise en place d'un périmètre d'étude
pour le centre-ville objectifs du
dispositif préserver le village réguler
les constructions de logements les
explications de nicolas d'andry le
village coeur historique de la commune
de guyancourt avec l'église saint victor
la ferme fortifiée de châteauneuf et des
maisons anciennes
un espace urbain dorénavant protégé par
un périmètre d'étude un outil prévu par
le code de l'urbanisme pour contrôler la
construction de logements maintenant à
chaque fois qu à une demande de permis
de construire sera déposé la ville a
à trois ans pour surseoir à cette
décision ce qui nous permet de prendre
le temps de bien protéger notre village
objectif permettre d'étudier des permis
de construire pour préserver le
patrimoine et de l'architecturé du
centre ville pourquoi là on est aussi
dans des maisons des bâtiments qu'on
veut protéger par exemple cette maison
là regardez qui est très hot février des
vieilles cartes postales de guyancourt
c'était un hôtel autrefois des cas
d'espèce différents en fonction de la
volonté municipale et de la zone
concernée par le périmètre d'étude avant
d'en être arrivé là aussi en nous disant
je vais détruire cette maison et
construire une centaine de logements
c'est le terrain derrière et est assez
grand mais bon quelque chose pareille
totalement inacceptable pour nous le
fait qu'on ait voté ce périmètre d'étude
permet d'empêcher cela on a eu des
longues discussions avec le promoteur
avec des allers retours on leur fait
revoir leur projet
plusieurs fois on arrivait à quelque
chose d'acceptable on a fait baisser le
nombre de logements on s'est rassurés de
l'intégration dans l'environnement que
c'était des petits immeubles qui on
ressemble plus à des grandes maisons
enfin il ya tous ces allers-retours avec
le promoteur je souhaite qu'on arrive à
un accord est finalement le projet se
fait maintenant alors je crois que ils
ont vendu à peu près tout cette
prérogative municipal va s'étendre sur
une durée de 10 ans et dui en cours
toujours dans l'actualité et qui
conservera a bel et bien son centre de
pmi la protection maternelle et
infantile
le site va déménager dans de nouveaux
locaux ceux de l'ancienne école
maternelle
eugénie cotton le conseil départemental
des yvelines en charge des pmi a acté
l'acquisition du site pour un peu moins
de 800 milles euros
il y a deux ans élus et habitants
s'étaient mobilisés pour réclamer le
maintien du centre alors menacé de
fermeture c'est un scandale qui n'en
finit plus depuis les révélations
concernant le producteur américain
harvey weinstein à hollywood les
accusations d'agression sexuelle se
multiplient un peu partout dans le monde
et dans tous les domaines mardi la
rédaction de tv 78 recevait sur son
plateau
anne-claude ambroise rendu professeur
d'histoire moderne à l'université
versailles de saint quentin en yvelines
elle s'intéresse particulièrement à
l'histoire de la pédophilie au 19ème et
20ème siècle et est revenu notamment sur
l'omerta qui entoure de telles affaires
extrait cet événement là est un être le
dernier épisode d'une histoire du genre
d'une histoire des rapports entre les
sexes que ça passe par des violences
faites aux enfants ou faites à des
femmes et c'est cette histoire là a été
placé originellement sous le signe du
silence et parce que ce silence est
rendue possible à la fois par des
relations de pouvoir et par là
le développement chez la victime
j'utiliserai ce terme pour l'instant la
victime d'un sentiment de culpabilité
pendant longtemps la victime a pu sentir
aussi coupables les femmes pouvaient se
sentir coupable de viol à tort alors les
femmes se sentent est coupable mais ça
c'est dépendant précisément de ce
rapport entre les sexes parce que tant
que les femmes se sont elles mêmes vécu
et ont intériorisé cette représentation
la dell comme décor à disposition des
personnes et où des corps à disposition
des hommes et bien évidemment elle ne
pouvait que se sentir coupable
eq intégrer cette dimension là après
tout si je suis l'objet de propositions
avancées ou de gestes déplacés ou de
violence c'est parce que il ya une
espèce de fatalité c'est que d'une façon
ou d'une autre je les chercher et au moi
j'ai grandi en dessous cette danseuse
dans cette représentation là c'est la
fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo autour de
l'information en direct lundi à 18h sur
notre antenne d'ici là restez informés
et connecté grâce à notre site internet
et l'application tv 78 bon week-end à
tous et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]